-Guys, I always say our show
is lucky to have
the greatest band in late night,
The Roots right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There. I always say that.
I always say that.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But it isn't always
fun and games.
From time to time,
we put The Roots to the test.
We're gonna pick three people
from our audience tonight
and have The Roots make up songs
about them on the spot.
It's time for
"Freestylin' with The Roots."
♪ Time to freestyle
with The Roots ♪
-Roots, you guys ready
to do this?
You guys psyched?
Oh, I love it.
All right, let's pick someone.
Raise your hand if you want
The Roots to make up a song
about you right here.
[ Cheering ]
Right there in the white
sweater, in the white.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, right there.
There you go.
-What is your name...
-Hi.
-...and where are you from?
-I'm from France,
and my name is Ninon.
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
I love it.
Your name is Ninon?
-Yes, N-I-N-O-N.
That's a lot of N.
-Ninon from France.
Welcome.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-The new season of
"The Bachelor" starts next week
here in America.
What is -- What's the most
romantic thing
anyone's ever done for you?
-Mm.
[ Laughter ]
I think France is very romantic.
-Yeah, it is.
I think, like, a dinner,
nice dinner
in a nice restaurant,
you know,
in the Paris atmosphere.
You know how it feels?
-Love that.
That is absolutely romantic.
I love it.
A nice dinner,
nice atmosphere.
What is an instant turnoff
for you?
-Oh, um...
The way people eat.
[ Laughter ]
You know the noise
when people are eating like...
[ Smacking lips ]
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Yeah, okay, okay.
-No, thank you.
-Yeah. The noise -- the way --
[ Laughter ]
-He took you out to
a nice dinner, and then he's
like -- [ Smacking lips ]
The whole thing was a disaster.
-It started well.
-Yes.
All right, Ninon.
The way people eat.
Roots, we have our pal Ninon
here from France.
The most romantic thing anyone's
ever done for her is,
they took her to a nice dinner
in a nice Paris atmosphere.
Gorgeous, beautiful.
France is gorgeous.
The instant turnoff
is the way people eat.
Sometimes they smack when they
eat their food, mouth open.
No -- turnoff.
No, thanks.
For this, our pal Miley Cyrus
has the number-one song
in the country.
We love you, Miley.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can we do, like, a "Flowers"
type of thing with that vibe?
♪♪
-♪ Ninon from France ♪
♪ Thank you for coming through ♪
♪ Dinner in a Paris atmosphere's
a romantic thing to do ♪
♪ The way people eat noisy
turns you off, yeah, me too ♪
♪ Ninon, thanks for freestlyin'
with the legendary Roots crew ♪
♪ I'm cooler than Jimmy anyway ♪
♪ I'm cooler than Jimmy any ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for being here.
Thank you very much.
Uh, who else?
Who would like --
[ Cheers ]
-Right here, Jimmy! Whoo!
-Right there
in the other white sweater.
Right there in the front.
Yeah, right there.
Yeah, you.
I like these white sweaters.
What is your name?
Where are you from?
-Amanda, from Connecticut.
-Hey, Amanda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amanda, there have been a lot of
flight cancellations lately.
What is your favorite way
to kill time at the airport?
-Um, honestly, just walk around.
-Yeah.
-Walk around, get food.
Oh, shots.
Drink.
Drink?
-Oh, you drink.
-Drink.
-Oh, yeah. I was like,
"Wow."
I thought, "Vaccine?"
[ Laughter ]
I go, "Okay, you're doing..."
Go get shots.
Go get some drinks,
get some shots, shots, shots,
everybody, shots.
[ Laughter ]
What is the worst food
someone can eat on a plane?
-Oh, God, um...fish?
Oh, fish, yeah, actually.
-Yeah, of course.
Yes, yes.
-Fish is a good one.
-Fish is the worst, yeah.
I would say, yeah.
That's pretty obvious, right?
-Yeah. Definitely.
-What else besides fish?
-Onions?
-Onions kind of --
-Yeah, if you're smuggling
onions to the Philippines, yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-All right, guys, I think --
Fish. Okay.
That is pretty gross.
A tuna fish sandwich
should not be on the plane.
Sorry.
Uh, uh, okay.
We have Amanda here
from Connecticut, okay?
And if she's at the airport,
she has to kill time,
she walks around and just finds
a place to do shots.
[ Laughter ]
And she does shots, shots,
shots, shots,
so that she doesn't have
to remember going on a flight
and someone walking on
with fish.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I'm not necessarily saying
tuna-fish sandwich, any fish.
Just fish.
Could be sushi.
Who knows what's going down?
But for this one,
since we're
talking about flying,
can we do it for our pal
Lenny Kravitz?
Maybe "Fly Away," one of those
type of Lenny Kravitz jam?
♪♪
-♪ Amanda from C-T
is a friend of mine ♪
♪ Doing shots in the airport,
killing time ♪
♪ And the worst airplane food
that comes to mind ♪
♪ Is fish with onions
at dinnertime ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah yeah ♪
♪ Yeah yeah yeah,
yeah yeah, yeah yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Yeah ♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
-Love that.
Thank you very much.
We have time for one more.
Who wants one up there, yeah?
All the way --
All the way in the back.
There's gotta be someone --
Yes, dude with the ski hat.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like that hat.
Yeah, come on over here.
Okay.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name's Jeremy,
from Pittsburgh.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeremy from Pittsburgh.
Jeremy, Prince Harry's new book,
"Spare,"
is full of revelations
about the royal family.
What would be the tell-all book
about your family?
What would it be called?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know if
I want to say it on TV.
[ Laughter ]
I guess it would be
"My Crazy Family."
-All right, yeah.
"My Crazy Family," okay.
And you're on national
television here.
Is there a family member who
would take up a whole chapter?
[ Laughter ]
-My sister, Jordan.
-You said that --
You said that so fast.
-Yeah, for sure.
-Definitely your sister.
-Yeah.
-Jordan.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Jordan.
Perfect.
That was very, very fast.
Okay.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Take up a chapter
of "My Crazy Family."
All right, we have Jeremy here
from Pittsburgh.
And if he had a tell-all book
about his family,
it would be called
"My Crazy Family."
And the family member
that would take up
a whole chapter would be Jordan.
Very fast, very quick to say,
his sister, Jordan,
who I hope is watching the show.
Thank you, Jordan.
[ Laughter ]
For this last one, Roots,
since everyone's watching
"Wednesday" on Netflix,
can we do something in the style
of, like,
the "Goo Goo Muck," the dance --
The Cramps?
♪♪
-♪ Jeremy from Pittsburgh,
are you still there? ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, tell all
about your family ♪
♪ Wouldn't be called "Spare" ♪
♪♪
♪ It'll be called
"Crazy Family" ♪
♪ And understand me ♪
♪ The craziest chapter
would be Jordan ♪
-Think that's it.
Hey, come on, now!
I didn't know you could dance.
I didn't know you could dance!
That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you to our audience!
Thank you to The Roots.
That's how you do it!